it's a start of term like no other in
brighton for students
and their parents undertaking this rite
of passage
with the complication of coronavirus
adding to the anxiety
and anticipation i've been apprehensive
just because of the whole
if we lock down and i'm still paying for
a degree that i'm not getting i think
that's
what i'm worried about um and also
paying for rent that i might not
like be staying here if i'm going home i
did think oh
if she's going to be virtual learning
for the next
let's say a year then i just thought
you know it's going to be a waste of
money but millie's got a timetable
and half of its virtual learning and
half of it is in a studio
students have been arriving here all
week to avoid a weekend rush everyone's
got a booked arrival time
and they hope that these and other
covered secure
measures will help prevent an outbreak
but across the country
thousands of students are confined to
halls
and online learning and there are now
questions about whether some of them
will get home for christmas
or even where the term should have
started at all
labour say students must be able to
return home at christmas
the culture secretary said that's up to
them i very much
want students to be able to go home at
christmas and if we all pull together
and
observe these new rules we follow
the guidance then we will be able to get
to a point where that
should be possible downing street
insists it has no plans to prevent a
seasonal return
but student migration offers huge
potential to spread infection
and unions are unhappy both about the
potential threat to health
and where the students will get value
for money they've sat on their hands
they've encouraged students back
students are now locked down into
incredibly expensive accommodation
because this government would rather the
staff and students and
university communities pay with their
health then they actually pay to sustain
the sector
term starts this week in leeds 2 where
the city is under local lockdown
and households can't mix new arrivals
know they may face a long haul i think
at the end of the day to guarantee the
safety and lives of people
if we can't go in for christmas then
that's just the sacrifice we have to
make
really upsetting because i'm like i'm
really attached to my family
and it would be really hard if i spend
all of that time without seeing them
but like hopefully hopefully that's not
going to happen and that won't be the
case and i'll be able to go back home
and then be able to come back to to
continue my studies here
i think that'd be a huge play like i'd
be devastated it'd be really upsetting
but we'd make
i really can't see that we can make the
most of it but
everyone would be pretty unhappy with
that these young people have already had
their final year of school
and their exams derailed by covid their
first taste of university
may prove no more straightforward paul
kelso sky news in brighton